BORIS DEBIC: Welcome,
everybody, to one more Talks
at Google event.
Today with us is Mark Binelli.
His new book is
called "Screamin'
Jay Hawkins' All-Time
Greatest Hits."
The rhythm and blues wild
man Screamin' Jay Hawkins
only had a single hit, the
classic "I Put a Spell on You,"
and he was often written off
as a novelty act, or worse,
an offense to his race.
But his myth making
was legendary.
Mark Binelli embraces
the man and legend
to create a fantastical
portrait of this unlikeliest
of protagonists.
At "Rolling Stone,"
Binelli has profiled
some of the greatest
musicians of our time,
and this novel plays with
a focus and authenticity
in much music writing
about African-Americans.
Binelli is the author of
"Detroit City is the Place
to Be," and "Sacco and
Vanzetti Must Die,"
as well as contributing
editor at "Rolling Stone"
and "Men's Journal."
Please join me in welcoming
Mark Binelli to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK BINELLI: Thank you
so much for having me.
Yeah, it's a real
treat to be here,
and I'm going to read a
section quick section first,
and then I'll talk
a little bit more
about how I came
to write the book,
and just tell you a bit more
about Screamin' Jay Hawkins.
I guess even for people
who haven't heard of Jay,
you've probably heard
"I Put a Spell on You,"
or some version of that song.
It's his one hit, as Boris said.
It was recorded in 1956.
It's been covered many times.
The most famous version of it
is probably not his version,
but a version done
by Nina Simone.
Creedence Clearwater
Revival did a rock version
that's pretty popular.
And then years later, people
like Marilyn Manson covered it.
It was sampled by the
Notorious B.I.G. in the song
"Kick in the Door" to
pretty great effect.
And later years, She and
Him covered the song.
And his own version has been
used in films and commercials.
So I was-- his own
penchant for myth making
is what really kind of brought
me to Jay as a subject,
and I'll talk a little bit more
about that after this reading.
The section I'm
going to read for you
is about part of his myth that
sort of came up posthumously.
He died in 1989.
A year or two later,
stories started
to appear in the press
about how he had made claims
before he died that
he had fathered up
to 75 illegitimate children.
And somebody created
a website, actually,
called Jay's Kids,
which basically put out
a call to these children
to come forward,
register with the website.
There was some talk of
making a documentary film
and actually having a family
reunion of these kids.
I'm not really sure if
any of this ever happened.
But the scene I'm
about to read kind
of imagines what this
family reunion might
have been had it taken place.
Funnily enough, it's the
only scene in the book
that Jay himself doesn't
appear in, because he's dead.
But it's pretty self-contained.
I think that's all
you need to know.
So here we go.
They began arriving
at the Sunset Marquis
just after 7:00, though
the invitation said 8:00.
A young white girl
holding a clipboard
greeted them enthusiastically
in the lobby.
"Oh, Mr. Hendricks,
welcome," she
said to Marvin Hendricks, who
arrived at closer to 8:30.
"How was your flight
from Detroit, correct?"
She was correct.
She also made
clear her knowledge
of what he did for a
living-- a staff therapist
at a juvenile detention center--
and certain family details--
two kids.
And Marvin got the
sense as she ushered him
toward the courtyard pool area,
where the reunion was taking
place, that she had
probably also memorized
his age and marital status--
37, divorced-- as well as,
of course, his ranking
among the bastards.
According to a
password-protected section
of the official
World Wide Web site,
Marvin was the 13th male and
24th overall of Screamin'
Jay Hawkins'
extramarital offspring.
They'd come from Philadelphia,
Paris, Southern California,
Juneau, Texas, Tallahassee,
Guanajuato, Coney Island.
They displayed a multiplicity of
ages, body types, complexions,
styles of dress.
The youngest, a 7-year-old
from Bowling Green, Kentucky,
was accompanied by an
ever-watchful mother.
The oldest, a 53-year-old
surgeon practicing in Toronto,
brought his own teenage
daughter, a first-year art
history major at
McGill, who wanted
to take a tour of
the new Getty Center
and see the Hollywood
Walk of Fame.
One of the brothers
had actually dressed
like Jay-- cape,
skull staff, bones
through his nose, the works.
Though maybe he wasn't
actually a brother, but just
some guy hired by the
organizers of the event.
They'd shown up for
a variety of reasons.
Some, like Janessa, an airline
pilot based out of Minneapolis,
had known their father's
identity from an early age.
For others, the revelation
had come more recently
and been received as a
seismic shift-- Marvin,
for example, whose mother, an
11th-grade English teacher,
private and bookish, had
always refused to say much
about his biological
father, except that she
hadn't known him, really,
beyond that one-night stand.
He'd come through Detroit
while on military leave,
died in Vietnam.
But something one of
Martin's uncles had said,
a crack one Christmas
Eve, had always
made him suspect the
Vietnam story was bullshit.
Marvin read his uncle's hint
as implying his true father
had been a musician
of some renown,
genetic fantasy Marvin found
both flattering and certainly
more fun to secretly
speculate upon.
Had Otis Redding or Miles
Davis, gigging in Detroit one
winter eve in 1965,
found themselves
smitten by the young cocktail
waitress at Baker's Keyboard
Lounge?
Or perhaps, it being
Detroit, after all,
one of The Temptations?
Or even-- would his mother
provide such a throbbing neon
clue-- Marvin Gaye himself?
She finally confessed
in the most awkward way
possible, at one of their
regular Wednesday dinners.
As Martin sat down
at the table, he
noticed a newspaper
clipping neatly folded
and tucked beneath his
napkin-- a short article
about how the late
musician responsible for "I
Put a Spell on
You," a son Marvin
only knew from the
Nina Simone version,
had fathered scores of
illegitimate children,
all of whom had been invited to
attend a family reunion in Los
Angeles, providing they
brought some manner of proof
and were willing to sign a
release form for a planned
documentary.
"Marvin Gaye?" his
mother exclaimed
when he revealed his own
long-harbored notions.
"But you know you're named
after your grandfather's best
friend, Marvin Sturgis."
Marvin had known
that, of course,
but had convinced
himself Sturgis must
be a convenient cover story.
Screamin' Jay Hopkins,
though-- a number
of the children,
not only Marvin,
found this news
difficult to process.
They went out to record
stores, some of them
for the first time in years,
picked up greatest hits CDs,
and listened to their
father's strange, jokey tunes,
while scrutinizing
liner notes photographs
for some trace of a
familial resemblance,
poring over the details
of the old man's
ridiculous, unbelievable life.
They'd all come to
the reunion bearing
varying degrees of skepticism.
Some of them wondered if
the organizers of the event
hoped to turn
their group meeting
into a kind of freak show.
Others held vague
hopes of a surprise
a monetary reward, some
manner of deathbed amends
ordered by their absent father,
and came picturing dozens
of gathered heirs
seated in folding chairs
beneath a massive tent
as a lawyer solemnly read
from the revised will.
Most of them hoped to find,
to a greater or lesser degree,
some trace of themselves,
something that had existed out
in the world for
these many years,
scattered but a
true part of them,
something no one
could deny is real.
Over the course of
the evening, Marvin
met a catalog photographer, a
dogcatcher, a meteorologist,
an Asian studies professor,
a retired professional soccer
coach, a coder at
Netscape, a janitor,
a 26-year-old mother of
five from the Bay Area,
a gay, single dad from Wichita.
They'd all missed having
a biological father
around, even though some had
stepdads or other surrogates--
in Marvin's case, his
mother's two older brothers.
They shared such intimacies,
delicately at first.
A few of them flirted in
spite of the unspoken taboo.
Marvin had lived in
an international dorm
at the University of Michigan,
and one of the Indian guys down
the hall had taught him a
few curse words in Hindi,
including one Marvin remembered
to this day-- bhenchod,
which his friend had
translated as "sister fucker,"
and which Marvin
had for some reason
found enduringly
amusing as he explained
to a young lady from Baltimore
as she sipped a cloudy drink
from a Martini glass.
A young lady-- his half
sister, the context being they
both spotted the dogcatcher
shamelessly hitting
on the Asian studies
professor, though if he
was forced to be
completely honest,
Marvin would have had to admit
that his injection of sister
fucking into the conversation
was not wholly innocent
of suggestive intent.
She didn't bite, though.
Or rather, she
might have, but they
were interrupted by
another half brother, who
introduced himself.
This sort of interruption
was happening all evening,
of course, the reunion being a
reunion of complete strangers,
after all, and who turned out
to be the only working musician
Marvin would meet that evening.
He lived in Nashville,
he said, where
he'd been doing steady
session work as a bass
player for the past decade
or so-- "Stuff you'd never
have heard of, man," he
told Marvin, chuckling,
"unless you're
into Garth Brooks."
"You've played on
Garth Brooks records?"
Marvin asked.
"No, that's just an example,"
his bass-playing half brother
said.
"Cats like him, though."
Marvin nodded.
He never had any real
affinity for music-- played
no instruments, listened
mostly to the radio in his car,
or to one of the handful
of the same albums
he been spinning
since college-- best
of compilations by Al Green,
the Police, Bob Marley, Prince.
Some older rap.
The newer stuff all
sounded the same to him,
knuckleheaded and abrasive,
though he realized this
probably just meant
he was getting old.
They also couldn't help
resenting the old man,
as much as they found him
intriguing, the mystery of him.
His songs played on a loop, and
whenever the most famous one
came up, they joked about
how Hawkins should've
thought about casting
a second spell that
would have prevented his
women from getting knocked up.
Others wonder darkly if
the spell in question,
like so much magic, came
with a curse attached,
and if perhaps they
were the result
of that curse, the unintended
consequence of Jay's
version of the monkey's paw.
You can fuck all
the women you want,
but every single one of
them's leaving pregnant.
75 children, he'd apparently
estimated before he kicked.
The insane numbers
had been reported
in the papers as a jokey, news
of the weird type of story,
though to many of them,
it wasn't terribly funny,
but rather disquieting.
Would anyone want
to claim membership
in such a messy diaspora?
Not long after his
mother's confession,
Marvin locked himself
in the bathroom
and began vomiting into
her doily-covered toilet.
He'd always instinctively
hated the man who'd screwed her
and ran after the war, or to
the next gig, wherever he'd
gone, partly because Marvin was
a bit of a mama's boy himself.
When he got older
he told friends
he wished his mother would
date, but in his heart,
he clutched her love with greedy
fingers, uneager to share.
Now, finally having
a face to put
on her fleeting suitor--
what a face-- it simply
wasn't easy to stomach.
"This guy," he'd
wanted to shout at her.
Jesus, the man was a clown,
and the music such camp.
He'd popped the disc
from his car stereo
after only a few listens,
switching to the jazz station
to cleanse his palate.
The CD case would glint
from the passenger seat
floor for the next several
months, mocking him.
Why did he come to
the reunion, then?
Well, curiosity, of course,
that was the main thing.
"And well, I don't know," he
was trying to explain himself
to his Baltimore sister
and country bass brother,
"as disgusted as I was upon
first learning of all of this,"
he gestured at the crowd,
quickly adding, "no offense,
but it didn't mess with my sense
of, I don't know, uniqueness.
But then I thought
about it some more,
and I realized, in a
certain sense this made me,
makes us, more unique.
I mean, how many other
people have a miniature army
of siblings out in the world,
biologically programmed
to have one another's backs?
That's the dream, at any rate.
Except I'm still trying to get
my head around the strength
of the connect."
He'd lost them.
The Nashville brother
had cocked his head
in the direction of
the ether, trying
to make out the song
that had come up,
and their sister was watching
this professional appraisal
play out in his face.
Marvin hadn't heard the
song before, either.
It was a ballad delivered with
unusual sincerity, at least
for their pops.
"My only prayer will be
someday you'll care for me,
but it's only make believe."
"Conway Twitty," the
country session musician
finally muttered.
Martin had to admit that,
as the evening wore on,
his father's music had begun
to take on a certain power.
The exceedingly strange context
played a part, no doubt,
along with his own
increased inebriation.
True, all true.
But there was something
in the repetition as well.
The Nashville brother
turned back to them
and mentioned that
he'd received a letter
from a conceptual
artist based in Berlin.
The artist planned to remake
all 31 Elvis Presley pictures,
only with Screamin' Jay as the
lead-- well, "Screamin' Jay,"
an actor playing him, obviously,
a response, the artist wrote,
to Hawkins' claim
that he'd been offered
the script for "Jailhouse
Rock" before Presley,
only to be rejected by studio
bosses as too scary and too
black.
The artist had seen a
photograph of the session player
in a news story in Der
Spiegel about Jay's children
and found the
resemblance uncanny,
and she wanted to talk to
him about being her Jay.
The Nashville brother said
he was considering the offer,
though he'd done some research
on her earlier work, which
involved quite a bit of nudity,
along with certain Christian
imagery that could be
interpreted as sacrilegious,
and worried it might prove
controversial in a way that
could hamper future gigs.
"Nashville is still a
pretty conservative town,
you know," he said.
Marvin, really all of
them, to a half sibling,
had nurtured secret hopes of
the party turning into something
like an actual family
reunion-- not immediately,
of course, but over the
course of the evening, primed
by the power of suggestion,
and, who could say,
a certain sort of
striving or refusal
to take no for an answer, born
of the same stubborn Hawkins
gene that collectively
would bond the group in ways
that they could never predict.
They wanted, in other
words, to believe
in the triumph of nature.
They vowed as they parted
ways at the end of the night
to do it again each year
in different cities,
to never lose touch
with one another.
But the cameras only
came the one time.
And it's not clear if they
ever followed through.
So that's just a little
scene from the book.
So I thought I'd just tell you
a little bit about my background
and how I came to
write this book.
I've been a contributing
writer at "Rolling Stone"
for-- been a
contributor since 2000,
and I started freelancing
for them even before that.
In the early days I wrote
primarily about music.
More recently, I've shifted
to writing about politics
and general features.
I wrote a book, a nonfiction
book, about Detroit--
"Detroit City is the Place to
Be"-- that came out in 2012.
But as I said, I started
at "Rolling Stone"
primarily as a music writer,
and I came to music writing
in a kind of roundabout way.
A lot of people on staff
at "Rolling Stone" who
focus on music are
hard-core music writers,
like old-school
record store-type guys
who just know everything.
I can't hang with them.
I came to writing about
musicians more as a writer,
meaning I like to
profile musicians
because they're
generally very extreme
and interesting characters.
I was writing about different
sorts of arts and culture
for a while.
And when you interview actors
or other sorts of artists,
they're much more
controlling-- excuse me--
controlling of their image
than musicians,
who are much more
likely to kind of
let it all hang out
and just be themselves.
Which, for a writer,
that's ideal.
So my first feature, my first
profile for "Rolling Stone,"
was a one-page profile at
the front of the magazine,
was Mo Tucker, the drummer
from The Velvet Underground,
who at the time, I
was living in Atlanta.
She was living in South Georgia.
She was actually
working in a Wal-Mart.
She had-- the Velvet Underground
had reunited and done
a brief tour, but then
it kind of fell apart
because of some conflicts
between Lou Reed and Sterling
Morrison, I believe, or maybe
it was Lou Reed and Cale.
But anyway, she was
left back at Wal-Mart
working in this little
town in South Georgia.
So for that very first
story, I drove down there
and sat with her
at a kitchen table,
heard from her about
learning the Wal-Mart cheer.
My first longer feature was
a profile of Hank Williams
III, who's the son of
Hank Jr. He looks--
if anyone has seen him, he looks
eerily like his grandfather.
He's tall and skinny and
sounds exactly like him.
But he was performing a mixture
of classic country tunes
like his grandfather's
and thrash metal and punk.
And that story actually got
him sent to rehab, weirdly.
I drove up to Nashville
to meet with him.
We took a tour
bus from Nashville
to Hot Springs, Arkansas,
where he had a gig.
Before we even
left Nashville, he
stopped at his drug
dealer's house, talked
about drinking and
doing drugs, or was
doing that the
entire weekend I was
with him, which didn't
seem like a huge deal to me
because in the rock world
and the hip-hop world,
none of that stuff is
that big of a deal.
Apparently it is a big
deal in the country world.
And so after my
story ran, he was
summoned to his record label.
And when he got there, they
had staged an intervention.
Waylon Jennings was
there, his father,
the guy who wrote the
song "Ring of Fire."
So I felt kind of
bad about that.
But I did early stories--
in the early days,
it seemed like whenever I did
a profile of a rapper or an R&B
artist, they would
take me bowling, oddly.
I went bowling in
Columbus, Ohio,
with Bizzy Bone of
Bone Thugs-n-Harmony.
I went bowling with
Outkast in Atlanta.
I started to feel like I was
being profiled, possibly,
that they were thinking,
what is this nerdy white guy
gonna want to do?
Let's take him bowling.
That's what he'll like.
Anyway, the thing I found
after years of doing this
was that fringier
characters in the rock world
were much more interesting
to me than some
of the bigger
superstars, which takes
us to Screamin' Jay Hawkins.
I've profiled-- I've
written cover stories
for "Rolling Stone" about
really huge artists.
And I found over the
years that the more people
I meet at parties or
friends, the more they're
interested in a
particular artist, that
tends to be inversely
proportional
to how interesting they end
up being to me as a writer.
So I've written cover stories
about Paul McCartney, Bruce
Springsteen, Jay-Z,
Radiohead, Britney Spears,
and really with the
exception of Britney Spears,
I found them all really likable
and smart and interesting,
but because they're
such huge stars,
there's just a
level of distance.
Even though it's "Rolling
Stone" and we get lots of time
with them, it's really hard
to get them off message.
When they've gotten
to that level,
they've generally
gotten very good
at saying what they want to say,
no matter what you ask them,
and your access is
somewhat limited.
So again, for me, musicians who
are sort of on the periphery
became what I kind of really
loved writing about more.
In the case of Jay
Hawkins, who recorded
"I Put a Spell on
You" in 1956, he
was definitely a cult artist.
I first heard "I
Put a Spell on You"
probably in the Jim Jarmusch
film "Stranger than Paradise,"
which was an independent film
that came out in the mid-'80s.
I saw it years later in college.
And in the film he makes--
one of the characters
plays "I Put a Spell on
You" throughout the film.
And considering it was
recorded half a century ago,
it's really an oddly sort
of timeless-sounding song.
I was in a pharmacy or somewhere
about a week or two ago,
and I heard they were
just playing a Chuck Berry
song over the speakers.
And it was one of his big
hits, maybe "Johnny B. Goode."
And it's a great
song, but it felt--
it just struck me, hearing it,
it felt very much of its time.
It felt like a
song from the '50s,
like of that era, whereas
if you listen to "I
Put a Spell on You,"
there's a strange,
to use the same word again,
very timeless quality to it.
It's a very funny song,
in certain ways, which
humor is hard to do in
music without crossing
the line into novelty.
Yet there's also kind of a
creepy, haunted element to it.
He obviously screams
and sort of howls
and shouts throughout the song.
There's kind of a
weird waltz tempo.
There's something about
it that really still
works and does not feel dated.
But it wasn't like I heard
the song and thought,
"I must write about this guy."
It was probably
many years later,
I happened to be flipping
through the liner
notes of a compilation
CD by Hawkins
and realized that he had
this penchant for myth making
that was just
unbelievably great.
In interviews, he
claimed that he
had been raised by
a tribe of Indians
in Cleveland, that he was a
boxing champion in Alaska,
that he lied about his
age when he was 14 so he
could fight in World War II.
It just goes on and on.
Even the actual recording of "I
Put a Spell on You," actually,
I think I'll just read a short
just a couple of paragraphs
from the very
beginning of the book.
He has a very funny-- he
makes some very funny claims
about how that
song got recorded.
This is just like a page.
The origin story typically
goes something like this.
On September 12, 1956, a
rhythm and blues aspirant
named Jalacy Hawkins, 27 years
old, a native of Cleveland,
entered a New York
recording studio
to cut a handful of sides
for OK Records, a subsidiary
of the Columbia label.
One of the songs Hawkins brought
to the session, an original
he penned himself, followed a
heartbroken protagonist who,
in a fit of desperation,
turns to black magic
to beguile the strayed
object of his affection.
He'd actually recorded
another version
of "I Put a Spell on
You" months earlier.
It's difficult to
imagine considering
the sturdiness of Hawkins
baritone, but at that time
he crooned the number
entirely straight.
His model was Johnny Ace,
the Memphis preacher's son
with the impossibly
tender voice,
specifically the hit single
"Pledging My Love," a favorite
of Hawkins with its
syrupy arrangement,
heavy on the tinkling vibes.
"I Put a Spell on You," Jay
said, "was a sweet ballad
when I wrote it."
Arnold Maxon, the
Columbia A&R man
meant to supervise the session,
wasn't interested in ballads,
though.
Rock and roll,
that mongrel genre
with its raw appeals
to youth, had
become the sound of the moment.
Hawkins and the session
musicians, to Maxon,
sounded hopelessly
stiff by comparison.
In frustration, he
ordered up a case
of cheap wine, Swiss
Colony, an Italian muscatel.
"We all got blind
drunk," Jay said.
The singer awoke the following
afternoon, worked over
by a brute of a hangover,
the rest of the night lost
in the fog of war.
Nearly two weeks later,
when Maxon presented him
with a newly pressed
78 recording of
"I Put a Spell on You," Hawkins
hardly recognized his song.
Its melody had been sliced apart
and overtaken by a shuffling
somnambulist's rhythm,
the vocal track
similarly debased by
a series of drunken
screams and groans and
yells-- Hawkins' words.
His sweet ballad,
ensorcelled, now
walked like a zombie, the
arms of his lovelorn hero thus
embodied, were no longer
outthrust to embrace
but to strangle.
"And that is how I became
Screamin' Jay Hawkins,"
Jay said.
"10 days later, I had
to learn the song."
So that's his tale of
how he wrote the song,
and he presented that
straight-faced his whole life.
Most likely, it's not true.
I mean he had been doing
that sort of shouting.
It's a long tradition in jive
music and R&B, blues shouters,
and he'd been recording
other songs like that.
So it seems unlikely
that he got so drunk
that he just somehow did this.
But it's typical of his
style in interviews.
And for me as a
writer, I had never
thought-- as a person who wrote
about music for my day job,
I never thought that would bleed
over into my fiction writing.
It seemed like I wrote
about music plenty for work,
and I loved doing that.
The fiction would
be something else.
But when I came
across Jay's story,
it just was such a
perfect picaresque.
It was kind of the
ultimate rock biopic,
in a certain way, just the
arc of his life as he told it.
And I also loved-- the
idea of writing about him
was such a perverse choice.
If you were going to
make a list of musicians,
iconic musicians, who
would be worthy of a novel
or a biography or a film
biopic, Screamin' Jay Hawkins
would be very, very, very
low on most people's lists.
He's not anybody's idea
of a super iconic figure.
He's a very cult
figure, and there
are plenty of people who really
love him, including myself.
But he's a very odd choice,
which really appealed to me.
He only has the one hit.
He's not very well known.
And as I kind of
thought about it more,
I realized-- I
initially actually
thought about writing a
book a straight biography
and really properly
researching it,
and approaching it that way.
Then I realized, what if I
just took him at his word,
assumed all these
stories were true,
and wrote the novel that way?
And, that to me, that
unlocked-- that was the key that
unlocked it for me.
I mean, it was
just-- it suddenly
gave me so many
liberties to just do
what I wanted as a writer.
And my mantra basically
became, what if it's all true?
And that was
incredibly appealing.
So I very deliberately did not
research his claims at all.
I could've tried to find
his military records
and found out if he'd actually
fought in World War II.
I didn't really want to
know any of that stuff.
What I did end up doing
was sort of researching
around his many claims.
So rather than finding
out specifically what
his actions were at that
time, I did find out
that there were people
who-- 14-year-olds who
lied about their age to
fight in World War II,
so that is plausible.
There was this patriotic
fervor at the time.
People were doing that.
I researched-- he
claimed that he'd
seen combat in the
Pacific, so I looked
into where he might
have been stationed,
what sorts of roles
African-Americans
had in the Army at that time,
how segregated things were.
That kind of period detail
was really actually very fun
to research.
And then I still
had that liberty
of making up these
scenes within his life.
I also was very drawn to
a few of the other details
that he had sort of sprinkled
throughout interviews
in his career.
One of them was his whole stage
persona was very outrageous.
I mean, he was-- again,
this was like '56, '57,
so this is decades before
George Clinton, decades
before Alice Cooper,
other people who were--
Kiss-- very theatrical rockers.
He was the original person
doing this kind of stuff.
So he would wear-- he put a
fake bone through his nose.
He carried a staff with
a human skull on it
and wore these crazy
capes and costumes,
and would actually
jump out of a coffin.
The coffin part was
apparently Alan Freed's idea,
the famous rock DJ.
And in interviews
later in life, Jay
claimed that he
hated the coffin,
that he would get really drunk.
He actually says he
developed a drinking problem
because he was so scared
of getting in the coffin.
He dreaded it so
much he would just
have to get drunk every
night before the shows.
It's a funny story, and who
knows if it was true or not,
if he was just kind of
saying that because it's
kind of funny.
But to me, that was
the moment where
what was kind of a funny idea,
taking this guy's life story
and making it into
an entire novel,
also had a potential for more
depth-- just imagining him,
this sort of cartoonish figure,
actually mortally terrified
night after night,
staring down death
and locked into
these dark thoughts.
I love the tension between
taking that totally seriously
and then also
presenting him, as he
was, this sort of outrageous
outwardly in many ways
ridiculous figure.
Similarly, his whole
shtick was very
problematic and controversial
as far as race goes.
The way he was
dressed was almost
like a sort of witch doctor
from a bad Looney Tunes
cartoon from the '40s.
He was denounced by
the NAACP at one point.
And yet, I thought,
he was possibly
doing some very
interesting things
with that in terms of just
playing around with audience
expectations, specifically
white audience
expectations of the time.
Years later he released
an album called
"Black Music for White
People," and I think
that's it's a telling title.
And I think he knew what he
was doing at a certain level,
or at least in the book
I imagine that he did.
And he, I think, was sort
of tweaking audience ideas
of authenticity, which can be
especially acute when it comes
to African-American artists.
And you can go all the way
back to blues musicians
like Leadbelly and come all
the way forward to gangsta rap,
that this idea of a
craving for authenticity
from certain artists.
And his wearing
that kind of costume
seems like a sort of
in-your-face mockery
and rejection of
that, at least to me.
So I loved-- in
those ways, I thought
there were opportunities to
kind of get a little bit deeper
with him.
So talking about
the coffin, and I
thought I would just
wrap up with one more
very short reading.
It's a scene I imagined
of him and his manager,
a guy named Stan Pat.
It's a scene of them coffin
shopping after they first come
up with the idea to do this,
and it's just a couple of pages.
The day after their meeting
with Freed, Stan and Jay
visited a funeral
parlor in Gowanus.
The coffins were arranged by
price in subsets of color.
Mr. Browning, the
funeral director,
pointed out the key features of
various models-- finer grains
of wood, the ornate
gelding lavished upon more
baroque grips and handles.
Jay, lagging
behind, ran a finger
along the center of a mahogany
lid, polished to an oily sheen.
Leaning forward at the waist,
he held his nose inches
from the casket
and inhaled deeply.
Looked roomy enough.
"How well ventilated are
these things," Jay called out.
Browning, misunderstanding,
assured him they were airtight.
They'd have to drill some holes
in the head end, Jay thought.
Easily done.
Jay cracked one of
the fancier models.
The deep red lining of
the inside of the box
brought to mind a
dissected animal-- guts.
He stroked the lining
with the back of his hand,
the way he would a baby's
cheek, or a woman's.
Something soft
caught his sleeve.
Solid, he said.
He allowed the lid to drop.
It made a clattering
sound as it fell shut.
"I think we're probably in
the market for something
a bit simpler," Stan murmured,
flipping through a catalog
provided by Browning.
On the page in which he
paused, the depicted coffin,
a rich oak, has
been lit to resemble
a perfect cut of steak.
"Certainly," Browning said. "We
accommodate the entire range."
"Father was a very
pious man," Stan said.
"He would've considered
expenses like these."
"This is true," Jay
interrupted. "But we also
want Daddy to be comfortable."
"No one is talking about
sacrificing comfort,"
Stan said.
"I just think we would
be respecting his wishes
by finding happy medium end."
"Happy?"
Jay said.
"You going to be
in there or him?"
"There's always cremation."
"He wouldn't have
wanted that," Jay said.
"Toss the old scoundrel
in the oven," Stan said.
"Might be kind of satisfying."
"Poor old dad," Jay
said. "I'm sorry he
had one really bad son."
"Remember what mother said.
Money is tight,
boys," Stan said.
"That greedy cow," Jay
said, "always grabbing
at 15% of father's
hard-earned income,
spending it on Cuban
rum, dog races."
"Mr. Browning, I hope you'll
forgive our banter," Stan said.
"It's our way of grieving."
Clearing his throat, Browning
asked, "Do you have a pastor
to say a few words?"
"He wasn't a religious
man," Jay said.
"Catering?"
"All set."
"Flowers?"
"What do you think,
brother, too much?"
Stan asked.
"Might be distracting
to the audience."
"He means the
mourners," Stan said.
"Of course," Jay said.
"And also too feminine."
"There's that," Stan said.
"I ain't Little
Richard," Jay said.
"You mean the
deceased," Stan said.
"Daddy was not Little
Richard," Jay said.
"He means the rhythm and
blues singer," Stan said.
"Wap-ba-ba-loo-ba.
An inside joke.
Daddy would go around
saying, 'Who do you think
you're talking to,
Little Richard?'"
"Not that daddy listened
to rhythm and blues music,"
Jay said.
"He just heard the name and
found it amusing," Stan said.
"He thought it sounded like
a slang term for a tiny--
you know," Jay said.
"He was a stupid,
stupid man," Stan said.
"Amused by the
vulgar," Jay said.
"I'll miss the old
bastard," Stan said.
Browning asked when the
body would be arriving.
Stan Pat explained
that they would
be taking the coffin with them.
"Private viewing," Jay said.
"Someone must prepare the body."
"Mother," Stan said.
"She insists," Jay said.
The undertaker said
this was highly unusual.
He repeated the
statement when he
saw the van in which the pair
proposed to lock the coffin.
On its way out the door, Stan
said, "we'll need a receipt."
That's it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Great to be here.
[APPLAUSE]